so you want to learn to be spider-man
can you teach me yes I can
how many more Spidey people are there it
can get weird
hey ma'am I'm Kevin Smith and I am here
today to talk about every iconic version
of spider-man that has ever been on film
or television the amazing spider-man is
Nicholas Hammond in the first
live-action version that we Americans
saw at the same time there was another
Spiderman live action happening over in
Japan in 1978 but the one that we saw
Nicholas Hammond was very special
because it was first time he got to see
spider-man in real life plus he was
played by a kid who was one of the
original family members in The Sound of
Music so that made it cool for your mom
so you'd be like I'm watching spider-man
should be like this is ridiculous and
you'd be like that boy was in The Sound
of Music its months since my mother
loved Julie Andrews in the sound of
music she was like then I approve of
this spider-man and we got to watch it
but it didn't last very long it's fun
watching him climb up the building get
him hold up the rope and he would just
do this he didn't quite wall crawl
[Music]
spider-man Strikes Back comes out circa
I think 1978 so it predates the Empire
Strikes Back is the best thing we could
say about spider-man Strikes Back is
somewhere George Lucas was flipping
through a TV Guide going Strikes Back
there it is Star Wars - what was I
thinking and suddenly he had a new
Knight a name for his movie but the
movie itself spider-man Strikes Back not
very memorable there's no scene where
somebody's like I am your father
you know and it's Mysterio or something
no it's a nothing more than a title then
of course it all wraps up with
spider-man the dragons challenge which I
was out by then I didn't see that one
man and I think by that point I was
headed toward the age of being
interested in girls and I knew that an
interest in spider-man wasn't going to
get me where I needed to be so I let it
go at that point I didn't see it long
before Tom Hollands and and until Dima
Guare was the guy who ever was who
played spider-man in the electric
companies spider-man shorts they
depicted spider-man as being mute which
really made an impact on me later on I'd
play Silent Bob it was based on this
version of spider-man he would have word
balloons that popped over his head and
you would see what he was thinking but
sometimes they used it to communicate
with other people in the scene it was
very confusing like wait are they
reading his thoughts but the idea was it
was supposed to be a word balloon they
didn't let the guy actually speak but it
had a killer theme song even before
what spider-man's always had a good
theme song of course in the cartoon we
had spider-man spider-man does whatever
a spider can but in The Electric Company
version it was spider-man
ah like it was pretty pretty mysterious
for a kid you know that was watching a
program that wasn't quite Sesame Street
then there was a spider-man cartoon most
people know because it has the amazing
theme songs by limited animation from
back in the day but you know is
definitely established in animation the
the formula going forward Peter Parker
has the secret identity he has
spider-man he can't let Aunt May know
about it he's got a girlfriend Mary Jane
all that stuff was in the mix in there
and they also introduced his rogues
gallery of villains spider-man got one
of the most colorful rogues gallery in
all of comics like there's Batman of
course then shoulder-to-shoulder with
him is spider-man because he's got so
many good Green Goblin
he's got hobgoblins got all the goblins
he's got Mysterio he's got Sandman
he's got vulture the list goes on and on
in the early 80s before spider-man and
his amazing friends it was just
spider-man and Doctor Doom featured
prominently in it witch doctor doing
more of a Fantastic Four villain you
know spider-man way outgunned fighting a
Doctor Doom but it was Saturday morning
I remember in the credits they would be
like Big Ben they should be like London
as if like kids to be like oh smite he's
got international but they figured out
you know we can make this way better and
they turned spider-man into spider-man
and his amazing friends which added
Bobby Drake his Iceman and Angelica
Jones Firestar and they would live
together cuz they're all going Empire
State University and Aunt May lived with
him she still didn't know that they were
all heroes and stuff in that a room
where things would flip and suddenly
like you know the control board would
come out little base their own little
spider cave that was really great and I
always loved it because at Stan Lee's
voice and Stan Lee was the narrator of
that show face front heroes this is Stan
Lee and he would bring you into the
story and then a commercial breaks who
Ben oh no what's gonna happen next so he
became a part of that series as much as
warmly as I remember spider-man's
amazing friends
I think it has everything to do the fact
that Stan was like the omniscient
narrator of that show
[Music]
spider-man the animated series I always
think of a spider-man the Toy Show
because that was back in the day where
KB the toy store was selling tons of
spider-man toys toy biz company that
bought Marvel later on made a bunch of
toys based on that line based on the
x-men cartoon and based on spider-man
the animated series including like smite
the Spider Slayer and stuff what I
remember most about that series was the
end
oddly enough what you're telling me in
your reality I'm a character in fiction
the last episode Spiderman crosses into
our dimension and meets his creator
Stanley fireman Pam hold my calls for
wiles of Stan as a voice in it's really
special because Madame web is a
character in it as well and Madame web
was voiced by Stan's
wife Joan Lee so they got to act
together in the series finale of
spider-man the animated series and it
was also just cool to see all the
villains represented spider-man's always
made for a great cartoon because his
rogues gallery is so colorful look at
and it was no exception when they did
spider-man the animated series in 1990
they used every every villain from every
nook and cranny that Spiderman even
crossed over with and also brought in
heroes as well there was spider-man
unlimited in 1999 and it was false
advertising didn't live up to its name
it was quite limited and it was gone
before he knew it it was over didn't
have the staying power of some of the
earlier versions of spider-man so in
2003 they do a spider-man high-tech man
like with 3d animation looks incredible
and of course it has all the earmarks of
the trappings of the spider-man story
that we love but you know it was next
generation it took it into the third
dimension because spider-man can't be
held by two simple dimensions so there
are three spider-man cartoons that have
come out in the recent years that I have
not caught up on your honor the
spectacular spider-man
I bite then there's ultimate spider-man
and then in 2017 spider-man and I know
my friend Scott Mosier wrote scripts for
one of them I think he did that for
ultimate spider-man or something like
that but uh no I stopped watching the
spider-man cartoons because they start
making spider-man live-action movies
suddenly you didn't have to just look at
animation suddenly you could see
spider-man in real life and it wasn't
the guy that I grew up watching on TV I
wasn't wild about the Sam Raimi
spider-man came out is definitely you
know groundbreaking I love the trailer
when it when they first start showing
spider-man swinging through the chasms
of New York like it looked really
convincing but then when I saw the movie
itself I was a little put off because
there's a big scene between the two the
hero in the villain spider-man and Green
Goblin and both of them are wearing
these masks from head to toe so you
can't even see their faces so at a
certain point it kind of looked like
Power Rangers just people talking to
each other like a couple c-3po s
nobody's face which I thought was so
silly because Willem Dafoe who played
the Green Goblin played Norman Osborn
has one of the most expressive like
faces in the business so they could have
just painted in green and suddenly they
would have been there but instead they
put him Sam Raimi put him in a helmet I
was happy that we had a spider-man movie
but it wasn't my cup of tea spider-man 2
the one that Raimi did afterwards I
absolutely loved with Doc Ock and that's
probably one of the greatest spider well
move removed one of the greatest
superhero movies ever made and that one
really touched me that it has a moment
where Mary Jane like says to Peter
Parker it's about time somebody saved
her in life really human moment because
that's who you got to remember is the
that's the epicenter of your story yes
spider-man's impressive and it could
swing and do this but it's the story of
Peter Parker it's a story of somebody
incredibly mild-mannered who when he has
the mask off you know it's kind of
milquetoast and isn't the guy who you
know
is the center of attention in the room
but when he puts on the mask he could be
this guy create this character of
spider-man who's engaging and quippy and
funny so I thought like Tobey Maguire
was a good Peter Parker but like his
spider-man like didn't you didn't play
like my spider-man my spider-man was
always cracking wise and his spider-man
didn't really crack wise so I guess you
can't really blame that on him but his
Peter Parker was pretty altruistic he
came across that way so I liked him and
then the third one
[Music]
spider-man three is when he's groovin
down the streets in New York and dancing
and doing this stuff and you know that
one was a little tough also had a venom
that didn't look very venom and Topher
Grace playing Venom's like hey Parker
he's kind of small so that movie like
you know I did well made money at the
box office but for me it didn't capture
my imagination I loved I had the black
suit in it the symbiosis don't get me
wrong but spider-man 2 was the
high-water mark of the Raimi trilogy for
my money
that being said I'm sure Sam Raimi's
like nothing you ever did was good so I
won't judge his shoe
[Music]
the amazing spider-man the one that came
after the first reboot very
controversial because we were just
finished watching spider-man and then
all sudden Sony was like hey it's
happening again
different spider-man different director
and all new characters and stuff playing
all new actors and actresses playing the
same old characters so it was
controversial because it was a reboot so
close to the one that had just concluded
and folks didn't know what to think but
when it came out I enjoyed it man I
enjoyed that first amazing spider-man
movie I thought it was the reverse of
Tobey Maguire playing face as folks of
call Tobey Maguire he he was a great
Peter Parker whereas Andrew Garfield I
think was a great spider-man he's quippy
and funny when he was in the suit no one
seems to grasp the concept of the mask I
bought it he felt like the comic book
page spider-man but his Peter Parker was
way too hot I would have this Peter
Parker you know what I'm saying and like
he was attractive and happening and with
it no glasses and stuff so that was kind
of a departure from the spiral from the
Peter Parker that I was familiar with so
that's the one thing I didn't I didn't
like too much about Amazing Spiderman
man give me the like Peter Parker can't
be too cool for school this is my then
they made a sequel had electro women and
oh my lord the whole thing went off the
rails amazing spider-man 2
it's got Jamie Foxx like
a friend once
it in account acting in a way that led
you to believe he'd never read a comic
book in his life like he was like
business what a bad guy sounds like and
then there was another villain - oh they
had the Hobgoblin slash Green Goblin
combo in there
yeah it was kind of misguided and and
you know it made a bunch of money but it
wasn't my cup of tea wasn't my cup of
web-one my cup of web fluid there you go
my fluid sounds way dirtier than I meant
it sorry
[Music]
nice job kid Thanks well I couldn't
start the landing a little better it's
just a new suit Tom Holland in his first
appearance of spider-man in civil war is
when we the spider-man fans finally go
there it is
there he is not only are they showing
spider-man as a young boy in high school
he looks like he should be in high
school
Tobey Maguire looked like he was 40 in
spider-man you know what I'm saying like
he reminded me of when I saw grease as a
kid and all the kids in high school look
like there were 30 so when I got to high
school and I look like a kid I was like
what the happened why don't world
look like Greece because they were all
adults playing those roles same thing in
Sam Raimi's spider-man Tobey Maguire I
thought was a little too old for it
where's Tom Holland is just right man
the one thing that Tom Hall brings to it
though nobody else ever thought to bring
to that character was he plays it with a
Queens accent yeah she down real flat
Thanks how adorable is that so he sounds
like a kid from New York for heaven's
sakes every other incarnation spider-man
all the animated series all live actions
even the video games nobody bothered to
give him a New York accent so I thought
that was ingenious and then I just buy
him I believe his performance I believed
his excitement at being involved with
the Avengers being called in for this
little mission and whatnot so yeah he
was a revelation and right then and
there I was like this is my cinematic
spider-man
[Music]
fine one of the things I loved about
spider-man homecoming was they didn't
show us Uncle Ben getting killed again
like they didn't bother with that stuff
cuz you know they are they figured the
audience knows it man they've seen it in
the Raimi spider-man's they've seen it
in the amazing spider-man 2 movies so we
don't have to hit them with this like
with great power comes great
responsibility part of the parable they
hit the ground running man we all know
that something bad happened to Peter in
order for him to become the man he is
today
that's the beauty of spider-man like
Stanley would always say like spider-man
is not like Batman or Superman Superman
you know who he is you know he's a
middle-aged white guy Batman because
he's wearing a cowl this parts cut out
you know exactly who is also he's a rich
guy white rich guy Stanley said that
even though of course Peter Parker was a
white guy from Queens quite kid from
Queens he said the real charm of that
character they realized was spider-man
was covered from head to toe so once
he's in the costume you know who he is
you know what he is you don't know if
he's a boy or girl you know what race
creed or color or anything that
character is so any kid reading that
book can see themselves as the character
it's kind of ingenious kind of wonderful
but that character means so much to so
many people because you can see yourself
in it and and the beauty of that
character is he's a boy completely out
gun he's a child completely outgunned
and outclassed but still he wants to do
the right thing you know and most kids
if you got that power when you were a
kid you'd be like oh my god I'm Ilya
rich which is what he tries to do in the
beginning but then realizes of course as
we know with great power comes great
responsibility
and turns it around and he becomes one
of the most relatable superheroes that
ever existed this is a guy who's late
for his rent who's always kind of
getting in trouble when he's not wearing
the suit and could pull himself out of
it just like that if he would just lean
into being spider-man for profit but
won't do that because he's a hero
my name is Miles Morales
I'm the one and only spider-man at least
that's what I thought we've seen various
incarnations of the Peter Parker
character and we all we know he's a
white kid but thanks to Miles Morales
whose character was introduced and
ultimate spider-man the ultimate lion
like years back and now is in spider-man
into the spider verse you finally get
the idea of that writ large it ain't
just some white guy swinging through
Manhattan now it's african-american
Latino kid Miles Morales that's what
they do with the spider verse characters
is all the elements that you're familiar
with have been slightly remixed in this
different planet or different universe
where spider-man is not Peter Parker but
instead he's this and so for years
they're a bunch of us who love the
character or like when they gonna put
them in a movie and there's been no sign
of him showing up in a live-action movie
except in spider-man homecoming the
Prowler referenced having a nephew and
everybody knows comics knows the
prowlers nephew is miles morales miles
got bit by a radioactive spider that
come home in a bag that the Prowler his
uncle had brought home and stuff as
Norman Osborn was trying to repeat the
same process that created Peter Parker
spider-man with my what he was trying to
duplicate it but miles wound up getting
bit he didn't want no kid to get bit and
stuff and thus the adventure begins my
name is Peter Parker Peter porker the
spectacular spider ham I remember buying
that comic when I was a kid and you know
it's his characters been around as the
animal version of some of the Marvel
heroes and whatnot in that universe but
you never imagined you'd see it beyond
the page but we live in such a such a
golden era right now where somebody's
like let's whip
spider-ham into this movie as well do
animals talk in this dimension because I
don't want to freak him out
pretty pretty astounding that we get to
see that in my lifetime before I die
a cinematic spider-ham actually so Gwen
Stacy and one version of the
spider-verse story
it's gwen stacy who gets bit by a
radioactive spider not Peter Parker
Peter winds up taking a liquor that
turns immense little lizard and stuff
and then when he changes back he dies in
spider Gwen's arms well which is fitting
because Gwen Stacy dies over and over
again in spider-man's arms and the
classic telling of the story she's
thrown from the bridge by the Green
Goblin spider-man
whip tries to save her but she snaps her
neck in the process so spider Glenn
having Peter Parker died in her arms was
only fair and fitting and whatnot and
then her character kind of got to go off
and have her own adventure kind of remix
hey fellow spider-man noir is kind of
like the idea of the Marvel noir
universe was you know what would Marvel
have been like in the 30s so they you
know tell a darker older version of it
not as quite ly quite brightly lit or
super heroic as you're used to with
comic book stories a little on the
darker side is pretty genius they got
Nic Cage to do his voice in that movie
and then penny Parker is from a
futuristic version of spider-man where
like her dad built this giant suit this
robot thing it's like kind of giant
robot like Evangeline or something like
that
and he's he gets killed and she has to
take on the the spider and so it's a
different take on it and so Peter Parker
got penny Parker she's a little Japanese
girl who controls this machine that is
their version of spider-man it's the
kind of cool thing about the concept is
you can do it a bunch of different ways
you know we all know what spider-man
looks like and what the concept is but
like you know you can go over to Turkey
and see their version of spider-man he's
a villain
the Turkish Spiderman was a bad guy
fighting Captain America some versions
of spider-man he could shoot lasers you
know whenever they'd bootleg him and do
them overseas and the Japanese
spider-man was a motorcycle racer who
was doing it to avenge his brother's
death you know so it's a character that
can translate into any culture because
that captures our imagination this flip
flip I'm gonna hit you with a bunch of
web and capture people it's kind of cool
and stuff but what makes that character
transcendent why it can go through so
many different cultures is because at
the end of the day that's who I think
most people feel they would be in a
world of superpowers you know we'd all
like to believe that we're Wonder Woman
or Superman or something like that but
chances are we'd probably be fumbling
through it and figuring it out you know
with a with a heart of gold like Peter
Parker well Stan we all to grow up
sometime I suppose even us characters of
fiction by the man it's time to go